why is there a salt lamp in our bedroom
why is there a black I'm bad at sleeping
and that's why I decided to go to
America's doctor the internet to find
over 30 sleep hacks to test this is
Sarah
hacks the internet I'm gonna be your
guinea pig you're welcome and then I'm
gonna talk to a sleep expert who's gonna
tell me why some stuff worked and other
doctors why is sleeping so hard the more
you put pressure on yourself to sleep
the more your body reacts and says oh no
this is a problem I'm not going to sleep
our anxiety system could be telling us
don't go to sleep because there's
something dangerous around the corner so
my body's just sensing danger all around
me and that's why I can't say exactly I
do live in New York City though there's
a lot of danger 30 hacks and 30 days
it's a lot but I got help I downloaded
auto sleep I'm tracking my heart rate
sound seeing how long I slept and how
well I slept after using each hand I got
my camera's all set up I'm ready to go
ready to try the hacks
okay internet helped me fall asleep I've
decided to split them up into three
categories the good vok and the bad I
got a lot to get through so let's get a
move on
here's the bad these are the hacks that
not only didn't help me sleep they
actually made sleeping harder don't do
these here's the first one headstand
doing a headstand this was a reddit
recommend it sounds like an awful idea
oh it beats some sense with the blood
rushing to your head and back in yoga I
can I can see that helping you a
headstand will get you going get little
rush to the head and actually my
increased blood pressure
would be bad for bedtime I couldn't do a
headstand and I think I woke myself up
more just trying to do a headstand read
a dictionary or any will make you fall
asleep horrible idea
horrible horrible I didn't have a book
dictionary so I was on my phone
dictionary.com you're reading the
dictionary are you gonna be able to stop
thinking about the worries no it's
boring sleep electric head massager this
is a random item I got off Amazon
because they recommended it to me like
how often do you prescribe something
like this to your every clients it's it
doesn't feel like anything other than I
have like a hard headband on my head I
mean it's supposed to help with
migraines and help you fall asleep but
it did the opposite for me oh I don't
get this one at all I honestly love this
up especially if you've just spent 30
bucks on it not worth it
ocean wave wall projector I don't really
know why feeling like a fish would help
me fall asleep if I was a kid I would
have been so into this but I don't think
it would have helped me fall asleep
I think it seems more like a party than
anything else this is like the waiting
for tonight part of the jello halftime
show hmm I'm ready to sleep that GoPro
light will not stop blinking
I just don't think red light is meant to
make you go to sleep so that in itself
might be a problem rewind your entire
day in your head so that one has a high
chance of being very bad so I guess I'm
just supposed to be like okay I got up
this morning I walked my dog when I hit
breakfast and then I went to work
probably not supposed to say that out
loud
I'll just do quietly to myself now if
you are like a superstar and everything
goes well in your life and you're just
like you know have a perfect day every
day
and great but for me it just made me
think of all the things I didn't
accomplish in the day and led to more
anxiety so maybe this helps people with
really high self-esteem go to sleep
earlier it's 8:25 and I am gonna go to
bed now wow this one sounds like what my
mom told me to do all throughout high
school going to sleep early Alexa turn
off bedroom light doesn't help I just
slowly went crazy for four hours trying
to go to bed early as if you try to go
to bed eight I'm sorry you're not gonna
fall asleep until midnight it's a waste
of time
honestly blink eyes rapidly for one
minute not heard of that one this one
was weird yeah I felt crazy doing it
like I'm giving my eyelids a workout or
something and they're gonna get tired
you just want to stay down wasn't for me
I've gotten through a lot of the hacks I
really thought that some of the hacks by
now would really stand out to me as
being really great and and none of them
have and when I look at the data overall
I still looks like I'm like not getting
enough sleep and so I think that just
makes me feel more paranoid like wow I'm
bad at sleeping but I didn't realize how
bad I wasn't sleeping here's okay you
know stuff that was I don't know fine
stroke your cheek
somebody must have suggested this
because it reminded them of being a kid
and maybe their mom helping them drift
into lala land distraction okay but that
just seemed really specific to one
person hum what about um humming humming
[Music]
the internet told me to hum and so I did
and I just have one question why a lot
of things could be good for some people
it's giving your brain something to chew
on
it's like mental chewing gum it's sort
of a like a placebo essentially so
you're filling your brain with something
if you believe in it it can help okay so
your secret in it to work mm-hmm
count backwards from five hundred I
never made it to one because it was too
boring count backwards from five hundred
joinha beeswax so the internet told me
that beeswax has an ingredient that has
apparently helped mice sleep and I'm not
sure what I was supposed to do with this
what about beeswax I mean smells nice
okay so that's chewing gum yeah probably
did you eat it I know I didn't eat it
okay
essential oil footpads just something I
got off Amazon they actually kind of had
a warming sensation which felt nice not
really great for me I feel like I'm
waking up in the middle of night and
remembering like oh you forgot to film
this part of your sleep hack and the
nighttime awakened like then it's 4 a.m.
and I'm like oh crap I still need to
sleep and I don't know if doing the
sleep acts is helping my anxiety if I
can't make the hacks work it's like I
can't cheat well let's keep going and
see if there's something on the list
that salted warm milk warm milk yeah
there's something there like oh I used
to breastfeed and
got me asleep well I'm not that I've
heard of but I like chewing gum and yeah
it's just hot choc without the chocolate
didn't work for me eat breakfast for
dinner I mean eating breakfast for
dinner is fun but didn't necessarily
help me sleep well it's not a bad thing
but it's not a hack Himalayan salt lamp
the internet told me that it would
filter their air and positively impact
ionization sounds like that's real what
amount of Himalayan salt well it hasn't
been proven and studies that help I
don't get it since I tested it my
husband has been using it every night so
he likes it cherry juice so ready told
me to take a shot of cherry juice
they're supposed to be like melatonin
okay and cherry juice that's what I
think yeah the cherry juice was tart it
was thick oh but ah so to drink it just
the cherry juice was unpleasant overall
not a good hack so melatonin actually
doesn't lead to sleepiness but it turns
off wakefulness well it turns off the
wakefulness hormones when we sense
darkness okay melatonin okay I got these
melatonin gummies and they taste awesome
I feel like it helped me melatonin is
not a good sleeping pill oh it is it no
it is not in studies it performs as well
as a placebo right oh yeah yeah sleep
mask if you're in a situation where you
don't have a choice you can't really
make your room dark enough then the
sleep mask is probably a necessity I'm
pretty much bringing the blackout
curtain to my eyes blackout curtains I
live in this
so there's never complete darkness so it
did help blackout curtains I masks
earplugs these are all great earplugs
obviously this is a hack if it's super
noisy when you're trying to go to bed
sound like I'm underwater for me
earplugs fell out it got stuck in my
hair but better safe than sorry
four seven eight breathing method that's
essentially when you breathe in for four
seconds with your tongue on the top of
your mouth you hold the breath for seven
and then you breathe out slowly free
again just something to control your
breathing something for you to focus on
it wasn't like amazing but it was
helpful stuffed animal well more
specifically reddit told me spooning a
large stuffed lobster with the claws
wrapped around my neck but the lobster
is good because it has this thing to go
around the neck so it's stabilized my
neck well right another another sleep
hygiene thing is being comfortable all
right that's my stuff lobster of course
at first there was a problem because my
dog thought that was for her as she
should but it was for me
surprisingly good hack weighted blanket
I actually been kind of excited about
this I've always wanted to try it
weighted blanket
I know people who just died for them I
get it now okay I loved the weighted
blanket it felt like I was being
swaddled this little baby again I loved
it I feel like I keep waking up in the
middle of the night anxiety is like a
big part of it but it's also my
temperature like I always wake up so hot
I go to bed freezing cold and wake up
super hot so there is something off with
my temperature regulation so it makes
sense to me that one of these hacks that
has to do with like putting on socks or
changing the temperature or the ice
water that's something like that could
really help me sleep through the night
cleanse your face into cold water I
didn't want to do this one but I did it
for you
bad there is science behind that
yeah it's called the diving reflex if
you jump into water your body naturally
has to slow down its breathing to
conserve oxygen so you don't drown so
the idea is you're tricking your body
into thinking that you're jumping into
water yes I feel a little tired does
seem like water torture yes actually
good for relaxing it may not induce
sleep per se but it may lead to a
calming my face actually felt good
after we implanted into cold water and I
do think it kind of helped make the room
colder 60 degrees the internet told me
specifically 60 degrees so when we go to
sleep our bodies naturally reduce the
temperature that might actually be the
whole purpose of why we sleep to
regulate temperature right so we don't
overheat throughout the day okay right
which is why some people recommend you
keep your bedroom cool closer to like
the the high 60s 68 was a much more
comfortable sleeping temperature 60
degrees was not my answer take a warm
shower big proponent of hot warm showers
before bed and so a warm shower is good
because that could do that same thing
where it's like a it's warm and then you
leave so you get colder taking a warm
shower does make me want to just go
right to sleep put on socks or is reddit
specifically says naked and just socks
so when you wear socks or gloves and it
actually releases heat right leading to
a cooling process in your core my
husband he literally screams if I touch
him with my cold feet does force me to
wear socks I kind of feel like this is
too much foot stuff is it upsetting
anyone is anybody into it smelling
lavender
there's lavender and of everything that
is sleep related what about the smell of
lavender it's good this lavender sleep
potion body lotion my husband referred
to it as sleep poison I do recommend to
clients to set up a good bedtime routine
pajamas
stretching right and smells those kinds
of things as a massage massage yep so
that's something the gas play yes very
essential okay essential doctor's orders
thank you
banana tea which kind of sounds like
manatee but it's not it's banana tea
wash the banana cut off the ends you
boil it
remove the banana and peel and then
you've got the water that's all banana
DUP pour that in a mug add a little
honey and there you go
banana t-not not great not bad not a
surefire thing a lot of these things
they may work once or twice you know
okay well we're looking for a foolproof
plan you're upset about the banana yeah
it seems like a waste of a good banana I
don't get what's in the banana tea
that's yeah I get it
I guess you could just eat the banana
apparently you want the peel over the
banana because the peel contains
magnesium which may help you sleep I
don't know are you sick of these hacks
like do any of them work well some of
work better than others I only have a
few little hacks left what are the
chances any of these are gonna be that
helpful to me here's the good try to
stay awake so the internet told me to do
that one seemed mean when I woke up in
the middle of the night
this actually was helpful yeah that's a
good one for severe insomnia
you can't not sleep and if you try hard
enough not to sleep right yeah you're
putting less pressure on yourself to
sleep and then you'd have a chance of
falling asleep I got up I went to the
couch and then I fell asleep on the
couch so stop fighting your demons and
just dance with them
most people with with chronic insomnia
overestimate the effects of a bad
night's sleep for most people it's not
dangerous to be sleepy during the day
during all your anxieties before bed
writing down the things that I was
worried
about accomplishing was kind of like
making a to-do list and therefore I
didn't have to keep thinking about it
because I wasn't gonna be worried I was
gonna forget it
so I think if you have the time this is
a good thing to do blow some bubbles I
don't know why I feel like I need to
defend myself here but I enjoyed blowing
the bubbles blowing bubbles there is the
science behind it yes yes
crazy yes and we can actually trick our
bodies into thinking it's in a safe
place by doing deep breathing okay so
bubbles in order to blow of level you
have to breathe slow that one was good I
don't think you can realistically blow
bubbles every night unless maybe you
have a nice outdoor area and you want to
before I get in bed but maybe just like
the act of pretending to blow bubbles is
enough it seems like a lot of these are
just ways to trick your body yes yeah
yes there yeah I wish the body was just
a little warm cooperative I know we do
have to find ways to get around it yeah
sometimes okay right the military method
I thought that this might be the hack
cuz it says you could fall asleep in ten
seconds and that the military uses it
you're supposed to first relax your face
then you drop your shoulders release the
tension exhale then you want to run
focus on relaxing your legs and then you
just kind of imagine a relaxing scene
and in ten seconds you were supposed to
have fallen asleep and if the relaxing
scene isn't working out for you you
musta just say don't think don't think
don't think shoutout to my improv people
I did not fall asleep in ten seconds it
did get me tired and Felton's good and
then I read that ADHD might interfere
with the methods effectiveness which I
have so I guess I'm I'm waking up I'm
feeling rested so even though the
military method you didn't make me fall
asleep in ten seconds
it still was overall good for my sleep
so and maybe it'll work even better for
you who knows
sapping a lot of redditors recommended
fapping before bed which is just orgasm
sex masturbation and easily to a release
and endorphins also an oxytocin ends up
relaxing the body feel-good hormones I
am in a stable relationship with a
partner so I had initially planned to
try the sex version of that let's go see
if I can get Mike to help me fall asleep
hey Mike Mike no are you sick I don't
think he was interested in being
involved in the experiment so we did the
alternative you don't want to do too
intense vigorous exercise mm-hmm
even sex before bed she's close to
bedtime because I can overstimulate you
okay so you're saying no to vigorous no
vigorous sex okay but you know kind of
like lame quickies okay works okay I'm a
little frustrated at this point I think
some of the hacks have been good but I'm
still having trouble sleeping through
the night so I'm hoping that the sleep
expert can just you know cut through the
bull and tell me what the actual hack is
that I need to be doing can you just
give me the hack that so ultimately
you're screwed if I if I try raps I'm
screwed I have to get to the root of it
right so seeing a sleep therapist can be
a great way to talk these out and really
try to understand them so we could talk
I sometimes I take people take my
clients walking in Central Park well I
think I intend to go to sleep but it's
just that I get distracted by everything
on my phone I'm thinking about you know
oh my god what I have to do they do I
have to get that shoot ready you're
getting like four to five hours of sleep
that's like really not enough so you
have to quit your job ironically doing a
video on trying to find ways to fall
asleep made it harder for me to fall
asleep
so me I guess we want quality sleep yeah
it's not about the quantity oh really
and what's getting in the way so being
on your phone yeah when you're in bed
not sleeping yeah you are making an
association with the bed that's
triggering the wakefulness let's focus
on what you can do in the environment
focus on right setting up the room you
can't try to sleep you have to let sleep
come to you you're you know you're doing
your sleep ritual knock-knock who's at
the door I hope this isn't a one-night
stand sleep
please don't ghost me silly ghost and
also probably like get your husband to
give you a massage yes I'm gonna give
you a prescription actually thank you
turns out the Internet's a bad doctor
maybe you knew that but did you though
because you definitely WebMD everything
if you're like me and it's things like
anxiety and stress keeping you up you
have to address the anxieties and stress
but the internet didn't completely let
me down because out of it I got a dope
lobster I got a way to blanket a little
higher and I got a massage but if you're
just a little bad at sleeping just go
someplace see Bose I made my own I mean
it does the same thing if there's any
other like everyday problem you want me
to try to solve or hacks you want me to
try I'm a human guinea pig and I'll do
it I guess just comment below
[Music]